you feel like we all look really
different I mean I didn't think in our
hearts we feel that but we get a lot of
people thinking like oh you guys must be
brothers you know in some cases twins
but that's a stretch but it elected a
hamma's
I don't know it's like an eye open it
depends on who's looking I guess but
well we've kind of decided is that I
think a lot of it that we don't realize
is in the mannerisms you know like
weights like a lot of times like this
will dissolve you to say you know arms
cross we do certain things that we don't
realize and I think people can just spot
it like the fact that we're together the
fact that we have similar mannerisms and
that we're just just close enough and
look I think people just really get the
brother thing yeah our voices on the
phone all the hunters and I sound pretty
similar like as kids we used to mess
with people and you're my dad recently
was like dang like it still hits me
sometimes like because I think I called
and he thought it was Alejandra or
whatever well it even folded our singing
voices for some reason are talking
voices are similar but our system the
one the one I've been thinking about is
actually just kind of has to do more was
sort of the way we grew up I don't know
why but growing up as kids I was always
had this fascination with like Japanese
culture if we took karate as kids and
like which I just love or ninjas yeah
but like like the samurai like that
lifestyle of just being kind of like
humble hard-working and it would have
something to do with Japanese soldier
Asian yes we had always started tell
like we were so young we didn't really
know what what like the music even kind
of was or like what made a good musician
or singer but like you always kind of
tell that other hand roll has like he
sounded more like what we were trying it
was Whitney Houston yeah like there's
something there yeah and then from there
we start to play instruments just to
accompany our quote he had to have like
the whole package and then it kind of
like took off I guess when he was like I
was 16 years fourteen it was yeah it was
it was pretty natural progression after
I mean I guess it's the obvious thing
like even just the tenor of our voices
kind of goes together in a way we're
like I can sing harmonies for that aunt
with them and it may just naturally
sound better than me singing harmonies
with you or with somebody else because
there's something about our voices that
are similar enough and I'm sure you're a
beautiful singer but you know that's
that kind of the obvious thing that
helped I think but a lot of it's also
just that we think alike but we also
kind of keep each other in check as I
could check the balances system we know
each other just well enough to learn and
we're not all on different pages and and
you know it just explodes but but we're
just different enough to where we can
actually make each of our stuff better
you know like Alejandra has he's our
main songwriter and it just comes really
easily for him but like you know for me
he's like really helped me as a
songwriter you know because I have
certain tendencies and he can kind of
help me with that and then I found
finding that we can kind of help him
sometimes you know so it's I don't know
it's like there's like a Venn diagram
like being similar but not the same is
some of the circles connect there's that
middle middle portion where we all are
the same that's very bad diagram
some of the best touring memories we've
had I mean at least for me the first one
that pops out is probably our first
Philippines tour we went for like four
or five days or something like that yeah
handful of shows refrain and it was like
like I just remember the first time that
we walked on stage on the first show it
was like inside a mall so it was indoors
and it just like the people screaming
and the acoustics it was just like it
was it was crazy like shook me it was a
really nerve-wracking but like in a
really good way it was like what is
happening I was like thousands and go
there because you always hope for that
or for something like two movie or to be
inspirational but like you I don't think
you could we could have ever imagined
that kind of a reaction inside that mall
like it was just crazy just so many
appreciative fans and they were they
were waiting there for a while just
because at the time that was set up
between the time that we had to
soundcheck and by the time we actually
finally could get out there they were
just all standing for like a few hours
and it was just like wow like that
intense passion that's up there for us
and we've had some great times in in
Europe as well you know like we did the
EMA's which was huge like in Belfast
which is a city we love playing it was
like 17,000 people and to be a part of
that right in front of City Hall was
amazing and you know we we don't do a
lot of opening slots but we did the One
Direction tour and their first big UK
tour and like that was a great learning
experience as far as just like all the
young kids and just how you know how
passionate they were about the whole
thing and yeah from their fans I feel
like to to their crew it was just like
such a such a positive experience like
everybody was just like ran in such a
tight ship and we just learned a lot
from that when the guys were really cool
so we've had a lot of really cool
experiences touring lucky you said a
hundred is one of our favorite things in
the world to do it's the best I don't
think they'll care yeah so we fan
favorites no I think there's nothing
there all I think they're all cool
they're all very cool guys and and that
was actually really fun to do that tour
I think when you go on a tour with
another band you you form this like
camaraderie whether you're the opener or
whether you're the head
you formed this bond because I
travelling together and you're putting
on these shows or whatever so we kind of
became friends with all of them but um
other things ain't cool I think he's
kind of got like we've had like some
good conversations about like our and
just yeah they happen to have a lot you
guys really connect on that level yeah I
can genuinely say that I think all I
like all the guys equally just because I
don't know like they all have a
different side of their personality that
like you know I can relate to or connect
with or that we can joke or laugh about
this sounds are ridiculous is in general
like I feel like a fangirl yeah I've
always thought about that like man like
who would I who would if I could meet
anybody who would I meet and it's like
it's tough it's like to some extent you
I don't know like you want to feel
almost like your people like there's
people I want to have conversations with
but like I don't know if I'd ever with
huge respect for people but I don't know
that I was like a guy would love to me
you know Katy Perry or Justin Timberlake
or John Mays Martin Chris Martin who
seems little Arius but like I don't know
if I don't know that I'd be like I'd
like to think we wouldn't be starstruck
as much because it's more of like on a
respect level than like a fangirl level
of silence around
I'm so glad we found us this way
yeah
well I get in this day and age a lot of
times you have to do a lot of things
yourself you know you know nothing's
obviously ever handed to you and a lot
of stuff these days is about how how
like clever you can be about getting
your message out there and like finding
your audience and and so for us we
always felt like the more we can learn
the more we could pursue our education
while doing music you know never
compromising the one over the other the
better off we'd be and at some point it
just worked that we all kind of you know
did did what we felt we needed to do as
far as the academics and then we're able
to finally get together and just do
music but I think it's really benefited
us you have yeah okay I need a lot of
architecture architecture and and art
based studies in college and that rather
early days really helped with like
editing our videos and knowing about the
right software's to use and stuff like
that so I think the opportunities a
youtuber just that we've had more
control you know like I don't know you
go almost create your own opportunities
I think the view take your own cars and
stuff yeah along with that I think the
beauty of YouTube is is to be able to
like the level at which you can show
your personality or your range as a
musician or as whatever you you want to
showcase whether you're a comedian
online or a director whatever like you
with these videos you can kind of show a
different side of you or whatever in
each video a lot of times people I feel
like in in all industries may get
defined or pigeon-holed and just one
thing based off of like one hit song
that they have and everybody assumes oh
that is them that is them as an artist
but they have so much other stuff on
their album or even stuff that didn't
make the album that they'd love to share
but in previous days it wasn't like a
platform to share that kind of stuff so
that's kind of the beauty of YouTube for
me whether it's like something has
instrument based as like oh let's for
fun do a ukulele song that's for fun do
piano do electric to acoustic you have
the opportunity to show your fans all
those sides of you know I think like I
think you have to kind of choose
something that works and kind of stick
with it there's a lot of times where we
even kind of we see people doing other
we question what we do because you
always have to like look in the mirror
and think like you know how could we be
doing what we do differently but we
chose something that spoke to us which
was do sticking to like the acoustic
vibe and and we've really just committed
to that and that's like that's what we
do and I think people come to like rely
on that they want to come to your
channel and know when they see that you
know you put out a video that it's
something that's going to speak to them
the way all your other videos have and
so I think it's just kind of pick know
yourself know your sound commit to it
and just really just work hard and be
consistent you know yeah I think if each
of your videos has like two two
different of a vibe like two
schizophrenic kind of then like even
might get lost like in the in the mix of
all the other youtube but if you think
about the whole package holistically
like you think long term like okay when
I'm all said and done and I've got 30
videos or whatever if there's like a
common thread that ties all those
together I think as a whole as a band or
as an artist those 30 videos will tend
to stick out a little bit more just
because you know even visually like a
lot of our videos tend to have that same
sort of visual look to them because if
they all kind of look different even
when you're just looking through YouTube
the thumbnails that just get lost you
know so look just think having the
vision long term with like okay five
years from now after this many videos
this is when I look back is this brain
whole you know it's kind of like even
like what Coldplay does on a whole album
cycle where the whole thing just has
like they have the same outfit the theme
the color scheme so when you look back
there okay those three years of our
lives this was the thing you got to kind
of figure out who you are and really
share that with people
yeah in a way that's honest and
consistent